good afternoon I think that's a kindness
introduction I've ever received from Bob
I will tell you since cuts are so new
and so fresh out but have a few of you
during our breaks and lunch I think now
that before I agreed to this book I
should have thought counseling uh he is
with on if you do not know in sheer
numbers the most written about American
of course is Lincoln the second was
written about figure in American history
is George Armstrong Custer there is more
words written on the battle Little
Bighorn than there has been on the
Battle of Gettysburg he had a
fascinating figure and the problem of
course when you deal with somebody like
Custer is in I know we could take some
polls here we have the true believers
the devotees and then we have these
other ones that I will probably not be
able to say what they think of the man
he's encased in an image and
unfortunately for him much of that image
relates to one day June 25th 1876 what
is constantly overlooked is a remarkable
Civil War career this man and that's
what I intend to folk afternoon is
Custer's career in the Civil War a
little background me if you don't know
what is born Ohio New Rock December the
5th 1839 both his parents Manuel and
Maria Custer had been widowed in from
previous marriages and they reunited
very quickly in that time be both have
had children so I needed a man for money
he needed a mother for his children and
in their marriage they would have two
sons born successive years and both of
those sons would die in infancy George
Armstrong would be the third son and
they called him Armstrong from the
beginning he was named after his uncle
and as he grew older and began to speak
his name he corrupted it to Adi and to
all his intimate family for the rest of
his life he was Adi Custer and from the
beginning and I guess because he had
been spared he was able to live the
parents thought him special and every
sibling that followed thought that their
older brother I guess in today's since
he was boiled rotten from an early age
you see this in him though from an early
age he doesn't change much these images
that have come across about this
brooding somewhat insane Indian killer
and dark figure it's it's not George
Custer at all what struck me more than
anything about him here's a man who had
such an exuberance for life life was a
thoroughbred he dumped on it and he
wrote it for every mile that he could
this is George Custer and from about the
age of three or four and he used to hang
out in his father's blacksmith shop he
would test the horses at a very young
age so he learned to ride early he
listened as a father condemned every
politician who was not a Democrat
interestingly of about the age of ten he
briefly spent some time in Monroe
Michigan with this half-sister who he
was as closed who muses - as his mother
Liddy Anne Reid who would married and
moved to Monroe Michigan he returned
from there came back got more schooling
came a schoolteacher and then at about
the age of 17 George Custer fell in love
now what does that have to do with this
billion a military career man well the
fact is this would lead to West Point
and we don't know exactly what happened
her name was Molly Holland but she loved
him in that age as you loved at that age
and he loved her and at one occasion or
more occasions they met at a trundle bed
in her room now we don't know exactly
what that meant but her father
intercepted a note about a trundle bed
and he had learned that this young
Custer boy wanted to go to West Point
but everybody knew and this is 1856 that
his father was one of the most outspoken
Democrats in Harrison County well the
local Congressman John Bingham was a
Republican now you're a new party this
is patronage well Alexander Hollen and
probably a mutual friend of Bingham and
so forth but Hollen
from what the evidence indicate went to
Bingham and said I want Custer out of
town and he knew it was five-year
appointment he figured the ardor will
cool his the safe and George Custer
received his appointment for the class
of 1857 at West Point now I know much
has been made about his class rank he
said later that there's only two
positions of note and then he clapped
the head and the foot and since he did
not aspire to the head he's decided to
settle for the foot and of course had
that class not been broken up and the
resignations he would not have ended up
at the bottom of the class but part of
your class rank at West Point is related
to behavior and George Custer from the
beginning from the time he used to sit
in the Monroe Church and teach his
fellow boys of his age how to shoot
things into the church at people sitting
there worshiping and a minister knowing
it was Custer and can't prove it
he liked to in our day and age say he
pushed the envelope
well west point he did he constantly did
he would end up with 720 or so it's the
third highest now talk about irony the
two higher ones would all be at Little
Bighorn with George Custer
Marcus Reno was second he would live Ben
Benjamin Hudson was the highest amount
he liked George Custer would die at
Little Bighorn but what you have to look
at Custer in it now there's certain
things he did admittedly one of the
lieutenant's who was an instructor there
he had a pet rooster Custer had that for
dinner one night
ah there are so thing one day he walked
into class and he asked the instructors
they're preparing how do you say class
dismissed in Spanish instructor complied
Custer stood up and led the class out of
the room but what you have to look at
about him what you have to note about
him is one year there is third year I
think he came to March that he had 199
demerits 200 and you could be dismissed
and he had to go to June did not receive
another demerit for the rest of the year
because George Custer knew how to behave
himself when he wanted to but he
preferred to test Authority whenever he
could
wonderful boys nature about himself
now I'm sure if there's anybody senior
to him you get sick and tired of that
voice nature a lot George Custer he was
by the way undoubtedly the most popular
cadet in his class
because he did things and the only other
ones dreamed of doing and George Custer
did it
what is up arresting Lee because of the
sentiments expressed towards him even
today every roommate at West Point
except one was a southerner his best
friend West Point was Tom Rosser Custer
early at West Point started reading some
of the fictionalized accounts of the Old
South and I think he had that romantic
image that we think of the antebellum
south today and he carried that through
which doesn't strike you but I will tell
you that once you became a friend of
this man you were a friend for life and
it did not matter certainly in the Civil
War what uniform wore you were his
friend and he was loyal friend as you
could find well as the events occur in
61 very briefly of course Custer they
needed cadets so what he decided to do
in the spring of 61 is take the classes
graduate the class of 61 earlier and so
they did in May
the War Department decided the class of
62 will receive their entire instruction
in roughly four weeks received their
entire instruction for the final year in
four weeks
by the way Patrick O'Rourke who who died
Little Round Top will be at the top of
this class oh and George Gus will be at
the bottom because there's only 34 left
and they were graduating June of 61
everybody orders to report to the front
apparently they went in order of how he
graduate or so forth because the
customer was still at the Academy and
one day the officer of the guard and
there was a scuffle between an OOP leave
an upperclassman and by most accounts
clearly Custer's duty required him to
break it up but he said come on boys
stand back let him have a fair fight uh
and the consequence was he was
court-martialed found guilty slapped in
the wrists and most likely John Bingham
who probably I'm sure just you know it's
stuck in his crawl to appoint this
Democrat in the first once it becomes
famous I will tell you the Bingham
adopts him and said it's all because of
me approach to it
somebody interceded and beside the
needed people now you know what
Hollywood has done more with him than
probably any other soldier really right
we keep this keep them out I understand
that it's possibly a new movie and works
down the road and George Custer and so
forth I was told to possibly Brad Pitt
his star yet my daughter is delighted up
I'm not so sure he would be a good
Custer but that's what I hear
hey is these elements for example he get
he leaves West Point gets in a steamer
and goes down to New York gets in a
train he arrives in Washington on July
the 20th 1861 he had been assigned to
the second United States Calvary he goes
to the War Department for orders somehow
gets in to see Winfield Scott and Scott
briefly talks to him and he wants to
know Scott asked him what do you want he
said I want
orders of permission to go to join my
regiment well they said the regiment is
with the McDowell's army at Centerville
Scott says if you can find a horse you
come back to the War Department I have
some orders for urban McDowell so Custer
returns in the you know spent that day
looking for a horse runs into an
artillery sergeant at the academy
Regular Army management stationed at the
academy custom knows him he had been
sent back to retrieve their horse for
the batteries have been left behind in
Washington so he agrees the horse and
they'll report back to army Custer goes
the War Department gets a the orders
from Scott the artillery horse course
sergeant had one himself and he will
ride all night he will get there before
dawn as an army starting to move a
little bit stir as McDowell delivers the
orders and somebody says well customer
asked where's my regimen they said was
somewhere to the front so in the morning
light he rides to the front flying
document and we'll be at first Bull now
what I think was interesting about it
the only essentially came under
artillery fire but Custer did know very
honestly that he said that an artillery
shell coming towards you has a different
sound than it did going away from you
and he noted that but in the retreat his
company Company G 2nd US Calvary was one
of the rear elements he was up all night
with him he would remember this man had
not slept now and over 24 hours he's one
of the last you do the field and a
routed army and Custer's there and he
will return to Washington collapse it is
from there though that it's somewhat
noted here's a the officers take note of
this man and so forth and he will spend
the next year of the war as a staff
officer in fact who spend the next two
years of war almost as a staff officer
yeah
initially with Philip Carney went come
to Peninsula he will be assigned to
Humphreys Andrew Humphrey staff but he
will be detached
with William Baldi Smith and the one
time that he admitted to in the ward
where he was scared was Smith one day
came up and asked for on here for a duty
Custer I don't know how much a volunteer
was ordered he went out and found number
one of the 30s lows but by his own
admission he's set in the bottom of that
basket clung to the sides and was
terrified in the first trip up he would
make two more sentence well what
happened previously Fitz John Porter
went up and the wind sort of shift and
almost blew Fitz John Porter in the
Confederate line now John talked about
this John Porter maybe the wind should
have kept blowing but anyhow ah they
decide to send up some lieutenant that
didn't matter if the Rebs captured him
it's okay and he would continue through
May then doing the duties of a staff
officer late in the month he was brought
before McClellan he had done some
outstanding duty on Peninsula and the
clown asked him if he would be willing
to serve and his staff of course Custer
leave did that and very proud of it and
he became as much as anybody become
Custer's hero now you all know what
McClellan was like Lisa pinions and John
reinforced some of those correctly which
I agreed with everything he had to say
today about McClellan and her bond but I
always was struck by the fact of how the
James Longstreet think that Joseph he
Johnston was the best general we ever
served under I never tried to explain
that I don't know how to explain it
and yet you wonder about Custer but even
his wife Libby would say that he never
had anything but this hero worship for
George McClellan he would serve with
McClellan all the way through the seven
days he would be with McClellan as a
road to team act in the morning after
the South Mountain as a cow he's fanning
out on the road to Sharpsburg at the
forefront is George Custer as a staff
officer assigned by McClellan to go with
Alfred Pleasonton and see
where the rebels are and he will be
remain with McClellan until McClellan
will be forced to leave the army by
Lincoln one thing I want to point out
though when this final phase he was with
McClellan Corson in October when Lincoln
visited and on October the 3rd George
Custer would write to a cousin of his
Augusta Ward she lived in near Rochester
New York she had parent Lee asked him
and she had asked him you know
won't you be glad the war's over so
forth I want to be glad to get home and
that now this is a man who had been a
Gaines mill but most recently he'd rode
across the field of the bloodiest day in
American military history he had seen
the carnage of war anywhere replies to
her and I quote you asked me if I will
not be glad when the last battle is
fought so far as my country is concerned
I of course must wish for the place and
will be glad when the war is ended but
if I answer for myself alone I must say
that I shall regret to see the war end I
clean yes
glad to see Apple every day doing my
life he would leave the army with
McClung because when the general goes
ah-so goes his officers but that was
good for custard returned to Monroe
Michigan began as she would later say
and that's Elizabeth bacon fudge that he
never let the carrot act of greater
intensity than he the attack he led upon
me he probably in love with a Libby
bacon early and he did pursuers he would
pursue any enemy of course their
handicap was that father did not care at
all Armstrong Custer side the fact he's
a person
he had been home earlier in the leave
and he had been publicly drunk in the
streets of Monroe and he did everything
he told it not to see him and so forth
and he did everything he could prevent
this relationship she would have to
admit later that it just eases grew on
and I think he probably did because he
never stopped by the spring of 63 he
will we go to New York City and he will
help McLaren McClelland prepare his
official report on the peninsula
campaign which is wherever you want to
think about that report but Custer
helped write it then in May of 63 just
mrs. Chancellorsville returns the army
right in the way from Taylorsville
and he will be assigned to the staff of
Alfred Pleasonton who had managed by his
means of controlling and sweetening
everybody above him and everything else
possibly become Calvary Commander and he
would serve in Pleasanton staff now
there are some accounts that for
instance place Custer as brigade
commander temporarily when Grimes Davis
was killed at Brandy Station on June 9th
1863 those are not true he did not
become brigade commander in the field he
did not in fact he was lucky to get away
because his horse slammed into a wall he
was trapped and so forth and he spent
the rest of day back with Pleasanton and
headquarters then of course the order
came on June 28th were George Meade to
replace Joseph Hooker as part of that
order if you do not know it Lincoln gave
me the authority to replace any general
that he chose to replace well Alfred
Pleasonton wanted some generals replaced
unfortunately Alfred Pleasonton was a
bigot especially against foreigners he
wrote some very revealing letters in
June of 63 saying this is our war we do
not want foreigners interfering in it
and he particularly meant Julia Stahl
and Alfred to faith well when the order
was received by me so forth of course he
met with some of his commanders and
Frederick Pleasanton was there now
there's been of course much written
about this in relationship
to Custer but he left a very good
account of that a month later it was too
Pleasant uns headquarters to learn that
he Wesley married and Elon Farnsworth
were going to be jumped Merritt and
Farnsworth were by rank captain Custer
was a first lieutenant
brevet captain we're going to be jumped
to Brigadier General now I don't know
exactly what Edwin Stanton probably said
when he read the telegram from Frederick
we're stocking staff officers here of
course Elon Farnsworth uncle was a
congressman that mattered a little bit
Pleasant and certainly knew that but he
chose Merritt and custard that night in
Frederick Custer said he received
confirmation about 9:00 p.m. and
pleasant and asked him what command do
you want and Custer said the Michigan
Brigade and that was the very custom
really relished at because a month
earlier he had been going through the
camps of the one Michigan regiment
trying to get a petition up the colonel
was absent he was trying to get a
petition up to have him a self-appointed
colonel that didn't succeed back in
Michigan he was viewed as a Democrat
everybody knew and he not only that is
they would soon use a phrase he was
McClellan's fair-haired boy but he is
appointed brigadier general in June 29th
1863 that morning he would ride north
from Frederick to find his command the
1st 5th 6th and 7th Michigan when he
turned out that morning he was dressed
in a black velvet team uniform with gold
braid that went from about here to here
you know a blue as he said Navy blouse
with wide collars to silver stars here
and a red hankerchief around his neck to
say the least well somebody said later
he looked like a
for a circus rider run amok ah why and
how the how did he do it overnight in
Frederick with an army on the March
I can't answer that question but I think
it gives you an indication of what
Custer was about now the count of Joseph
fought a bugler form Pennsylvania boy
got in the army I think at the age of 13
because he could blow a bugle this was
proud of the war he stood about five
four and he became Custer's shadow for
the rest of the war fought would leave
us accounted well custom new days before
that he might be made of brigadier I
don't think he he came back from all day
out at scouting and they joked and he
called him general he got mad and here
his committee was there well that's not
historically accurate there's no proof
of that
maybe when he was planned to become
Colonel of a Michigan regiment or
whatever the case is Custer had to have
that uniform ready and when the time
came deston pulled it out and put it on
now why first of all he wanted to be
noticed there's no question about that
you heard the words I quoted to you to
remember them he believed that ah he
would argue later that he wore the
uniform because he wanted his men to
know where he was in battle he would
stand out where he stood out I mean
there's you know long hair and so forth
he clearly stood out that was his
argument sure to he well knew that
newspaper men could see him also
but this man wanted to be distinctive
and he dressed to be distinctive and I
will tell you when he was first met by
the Michigan men I'm sure they said what
do we have here boy general the golden
locks was one and this is a diary entry
right afterwards I mean it's like two
days later they're calling him the boy
Gen General the golden locks you know
it's already there remembers 23 years
old he's a youngest Brigadier General in
the army at the time he wind up being a
young
Major General in United States military
history okay so you'll find them and on
June 30th 1863 they will get in the
scrape but Hanover with part of thirds
errant Calvary mostly the Michigan
Brigade fights in the skirmish formation
and so forth they press back and forth
there's no real serious fighting at
Hanover in the sent earlier there was
and they were called back and then in
the July ii as stewards approaching
gettysburg from Carlisle north of
Gettysburg means it's on them while
Carlisle isn't but you know where it is
with the map you have there and then
it's also of course you can see I'm
going to refer to the map in the second
map in the left upper left-hand corner
of hunters town federal cavalry will
collide with Hamptons rearguard see the
Confederates are moving south they were
patrolling north came in to Hunter's
town in the rear guards classed Custer
rode to the front deployed a company as
skirmishers and wanted to know what was
ahead along comes his division commander
Justin Kilpatrick who will quickly earn
the nickname kilt ivory and rightly so
and Kilpatrick was not interested in
skirmishers in probing he ordered a
charge by a company to come a company of
six Michigan so what happens is custer
decides to join in now this is the test
i guess in some ways this is the moment
early for George Custer and everything
that follows afterwards in some ways he
rides to the front of that company you
can see it there it's when that road is
narrow there there were fences on both
sides and at the forefront of the charge
he will lead the company right down the
road into the Confederates nearly the
Gilbert house it's located there
his horse is shot from under him he is
on the verge of being killed by a
Confederate when a member of the 1st
Michigan who decided to tag along on the
charge shoots a Confederate ramped his
general puts him on his horse and saves
his life when you start reading their
accounts and I'll tell you this in the
store and you go you know I love to
collect the regimentals in the memoirs
as all of you probably do and you know
many of them are written well after the
war when that glow is going over there
what they did and they're only looking
at the good things that happen in most
cases and in case of Michigan man you
must remember that by then you're also
dealing with a general who is being
vilified as a fool who lead five
companies in a massacre in 1876 at
Little Bighorn and they tend to defend
him so I came to those with skepticism
and her praise worthy of Custer what
strikes me and still does of course is
when you start to get into their letters
and diaries of the war already it's
there we have a leader we have a man who
is at the forefront of our command and
from that point now the real
confirmation will come the next day of
course but you're going to see the
references early what they write in July
a 63 is not what they will not they
won't change that in July of 1893 if
that's when they're writing again they
will not change that view of this man
and of course we come to the east
Calvary battlefield at Gettysburg a day
later
it's rather famous it's numbers of
dontre on e paint I did a print of it
it's unfortunate most people do not go
out to there when their Gettysburg
because the fields about the most
pristine of all the parts of Gettysburg
battlefield and as this battle will ebb
and flow and he is detached from
Kilpatrick and Greg will hold him in
place
but the time will come for Custer and
what Custer will do of course is as a as
the Confederates will start to push
towards the guns as you see down there
along the low Dutch Road
and along a Hanover Road as they come
out to give battle Custer Greg a
no-reserve accept to 7th and 1st
Michigan he will of course order this
Greg will order the 7th Michigan forward
in the charge Custer will come back
he'll ride to the front of the regiment
and say tell the colonel he's going in
with him and they will move forward and
he will turn and say come on you
Wolverines
what does strike me about that well
again I'll recount them though
they'll be driven back he have two
horses shot out from him near the wall
on near the Rummel farm he will return
here comes Hampton and and there was
confederal is all over the place and
here comes Hamptons Calvary in the story
charge the sabers were out it was I mean
read federal counts of ones who weren't
shooting out and they just marveled at
this attack everybody in his path
scattered they got out of the way all
its left's the 1st Michigan Custer will
go back to the 1st Michigan and Greg had
ordered it forward he will ride to the
front of it as the Confederates are
plunging towards lot out and going lot
home this is drama on a high level it
really is a good bit of steak here in
this fight they will begin you know
slowly and they will build to a speed
and as their ability the speed to charge
Custer will shout come on you Wolverines
what you must understand about George
Custer at least in my mind is the fact
that that was not an order that was a
summons I think if you look at him in
that regard and you can find him here
and we'll talk about a few other places
briefly in regard to that but I think
that maybe by 1865 you were looking at
perhaps the wars last night Custer chose
within a national tragedy and there's no
greater national tragedy in our history
to think glory he wanted it he coveted
it and it's almost as if he has this
personal quest he had a cause and when
he shouted c'mon you Wolverines there
were men who were willing to follow him
continue to follow him in other places
this is as much a characteristic as
George Custer as a commander as anything
an important thing you must remember is
that they were willing to follow him
the Michigan Brigade will incur more
casualties than any other Calvary
Brigade in the Army in their history but
when he called them to answer the call
the country and to answer his own
personal call they answered and he would
fight that war this way he would seek it
that does not mean he deliberately
sacrificed his men to enhance his
reputation and his glory that is wrong
and the men will say that they had far
greater disdain for Kilpatrick
sacrificing men than they ever had for
George Custer he will follow up to this
at Gettysburg to give you an example
following waters July the 14th the
Kilpatrick was with him Michigan Brigade
nearly and they learned it the
Confederates were crossing the river so
they rode to the area first thing Custer
does is deploy two companies the
Confederates are up in an all he doesn't
know how many there are
he deploys two companies to go forward
as skirmishers to find out what we're
facing as he's preparing to do that in
rides kill Calvary Kilpatrick counter
man's the order he wants a charge so he
orders the charge of two companies they
will ride into the Confederate camp of
course one of those men will mortally
wound
Johnston Pettigrew but they are
essentially wiped out one of the best
officers in in the regiment v Michigan
is Peter Webber
he's killed there men never forget that
Custer didn't order that Custer did not
order a headlong charge into an enemy up
there that he did not know of a certain
strength
Kilpatrick did Custer will serve under
Kilpatrick during the fall of course I
think their parting of the ways came at
the Buckland races in October of 63 when
Stewart allowed Kilpatrick to be drawn
into the trap and they were barely able
to get out of it that's you know in the
road by Gainesville and during the
Bristol campaign on a personal note of
course George Custer would get married
in February of 1864 to lybian Monroe
Michigan it would be a remarkable union
of two people much has been made of that
every attempt has been found to prove
that George Custer was a hypocrite of
course and achieved everything she wrote
about it was fictional if you do not
know this Libby Custer will live 57
years after Little Bighorn she will die
in 1933 and she is buried at West Point
perhaps beside her husband there's a I
don't know that for sure nobody does and
she but what I'm getting that anything
that you can find about this man and
he's easy to tarnish and there's good
reason for because he has flaws but
there's a what struck me throughout and
you read some of their letters I will
tell you that they were very
passionately in love they had a very
relationship those letters parts of
those letters were deleted from the
Custer story which is a compilation of
their letters in fact I think somebody
physically took scissors to the letters
and cut out those sections he was very
frank about how he felt about her
and she was about him they had no
children
that's probably because as a cadet it
wet well we know for a fact as a cadet
at West Point when he returned from
leave in 1859 George Custer had
contracted gonorrhea he because of that
because of the treatments of the day the
odds are better than 5050 that he was
sterile
now gonorrhea in that they would go out
would go out eventually leave you and so
by the time he marries in 64 the disease
was out of his body if you remember bud
Robertson's book and ap Hill he argued
that about he'll haven't gone to read
and came back if that's it
he'll it picked up syphilis - because
gonorrhea will run his course ah Libby
Custer will say later that she had two
great regrets in her life one of course
was his death in an untimely age and
secondly was the fact that they had no
children the only thing you're left with
is the fact that most likely George
Custer was sterile and he could not have
children that of course means that
George Custer could not have fathered an
Indian child but the odds tend to
indicate that but you cannot say that
definitively but what I want to tell you
is that of all these accusations are
going to be raised about this couple and
they star mean from he had relationships
with his servant hid relationships of
Indians you know he was fate not at all
faithful to his wife and that could be
true but there are small threads of
evidence most of it Benton who spent 20
years or so after ah a Little Bighorn
with one mission just to continue to
hate George Custer and he did that well
as I said he had a backbone of steel and
a soldier ah and of Banting was
courageous officer but he loathed the
Custer and everything he ever heard
about him he rode and they'd been picked
up but I will tell you when he married
Libby bacon Custer in February of 18 6
before he was devotedly in love with her
and it seems to me that when he rode
away from her as she looked out from a
bluff outside of Fort Abraham Lincoln in
that faithful spring of se teen 76 when
they parted for the last time they were
still two people in love and that's I
think important and she would devote her
life of course to helping to shape that
image anyhow he will return to the Army
in 1864 still Brigadier General now they
weren't going to confirm his appointment
John dealt so wealth of politics as you
can't believe it I would always like to
write about Confederate as the more
interesting characters I always thought
and I never got into the army topic but
is it just the politics infuses
everything and so Custer had to prove
his fidelity to the Union cause in
January of 1864 he had to prove that in
the letter and once he did that once he
publicly stating went along with
emancipation and the war aims his
brigadier her ship was confirmed he
would lead him of course through the
wilderness at yellow tavern as his
troops one of whom I don't know it was
Don Hall but one of the troopers of the
Michigan Brigade mortally wounded Jeff
Stewart what is more interesting I think
if you look at George Custer is a fact
that thought he was involved in the
fight at Rebellion station and I mean
that in the sense of what the men
thought of ah at civilian station they
got caught they came down the road it
was like Hampton and Sheridan looking
for each other and please understand
Sheridan would always take care of his
protege always would until the end but
he would always take care of Custer and
he ended up charging into the
Confederate wagons of course the one
regiment went beyond that Confederates
counter attacked his best friend Tom
Raza and Custer's men were surrounded
for roughly about three hours of stiff
fighting during the course of that
engagement one of his troopers was shot
down out in front of line Custer ran out
picked a man up and carried him back
into the line that got a lot of ink from
his men
at another point the color bear went
down in George Custer toward the flag
off the staff and draped it over his
shoulders and he walked the line there
one officer would say later now I know
why he wore that uniform at another
point engagement one officer comes up to
him obviously excited said general
should I take the wagons to the rear and
Custer turns and looks out and says
where in the hell's a rear there was no
rear they were completely surrounded
until Sheridan pushed through and opened
it up of course from that he will go in
the late summer of 1864 to the
Shenandoah Valley at 3rd Winchester he
will lead the Michigan Brigade he will
win be involved in that terrible
incident at Front Royal in September the
23rd 1864 were his troopers and other
troopers hang six of John Mosby's
Rangers I will tell you however that a
month before and the evidence is
overwhelming now there's been some
thanks to Bill Miller helping me and
even add to that you know 20 19 of his
men 29 excuse me of his 30 men were
trapped in a Lane outside of Bear evil
and executed by Mosby's men one escaped
that there was this bitter bitter hatred
of Mosby's men this war is not romantic
at all anymore you should well know that
people have a hard time accepting but I
believe me by the September 64 there was
no romance left except possibly in this
guy who wore a black velvet uniform
because he tried to keep it himself but
Custer did not order the execution of
Mosby's men that would have been married
and Torbert I'm sure he agreed with it
and he certainly didn't prevent his
Michigan men from executing two of them
but he did not order it even though John
Mosby for the rest of his life believed
it was Custer at the end of September he
would be promoted to commander the third
division to replace James Wilson Custer
hated James Wilson and the spring of 64
Wilson was promoted brought in from uni
had been in Grandstaff granted assigned
him the command of the division with
Custer rightfully thought was his own I
will quote from you two comments related
to that promotion to give you an
indication here Colonel Peter Stagg of
the 1st Michigan in his report said the
brigade suffered the most severe loss of
the campaign General Custer being
believed on the other hand well a
trooper in the same regiment right home
roughly this time he and he would say I
reckon are the devil now for the one of
a commander remember the third Calvary
division the boys like General Custer
there was some get up and get to him and
within days a course of his appointment
he would lead his third Calvary division
at the Battle of Tom's Brook which
became known as Woodstock races but I
only want to point out to you and very
briefly about this because I want to do
one a lot of time for questions because
I'm sure what I've said some you just
will dismiss and rightly so that's why
we're here to you on that day
oh by proposed Tom Rosser the savior of
the valley
remember sure it in total Tolbert i want
you to get rid of the savior of the
valley Custer was owner Raza was on the
hill Custer was in an opposite Ridge
they recognized each other and George
Custer rode out and graciously bow to
his old best friend from West Point Anna
course Rosser told somebody that's the
general that Federals are so proud of -
we're done with him today he'll be
running the whole way back to Winchester
well Tom Mumford never liked Rosser and
he sort of dismissed that notion but
anyhow it was all morning
testing feeling where was he until
finally the understanded they could
outflank him so Custer sent three
regiments around the line but this is
Custer - I mean it was a headlong charge
when the three regiments attacked
however George Custer died he's the
in commander rides to the front of his
unit and her some poor devil named
sergeant jumpin Buckley he happened to
be a bugler for the 5th New York Calvary
and he says sergeant you're with me I
don't know what Buckley thought about
moment in his life but there is in this
narrow back road at the head of the
command leading the charge beside this
general as one third division trooper
will say later the history of arc and
began at Toms Brook on October the 9th
1864 they were convinced too that his
Michigan men had already been wearing
red neckties as a bond they will spend
the rest of the war petitioning generals
and the War Department to have them
assigned to the 3rd Cavalry Division the
1st Vermont who had been attached in
1863 to the Michigan Brigade jokingly
liked to call themselves the 8th
Michigan would endeavor for months to be
reassigned to the brigade now when
you're talking these men these veterans
and the documentary record is there you
can get an appreciation what they
thought of him
of course it would be George Custer who
in the retreat from Petersburg on the
night of April the 8th 1865 will be
George Custer and the 3rd Calvary
division that will cut off Lee's army at
Appomattox the next morning George
Custer will ride forth on a ridge now
during the course of that week I think
they captured in a neighborhood of 32
Confederate battle flags what he liked
to do is he said he had an honor guard
for every trooper captured it he left
him ride with him so if you can picture
the scene on a ridge above Appomattox as
this great proud Army of Northern
Virginia the remnant that's left was
going to go forth to try to break
through but they were being stopped and
pushed back
but there on a ridge you're going to see
a general indistinctive in many ways
trailed by 32 Confederate battle flags
he had a flair for it I mean you know he
had that flair for it and the men loved
it
of course he also that day will go to
General James Longstreet and demand the
surrender of the army and basically
James Longstreet will tell young George
Custer what he he thought of him and the
fact that he can surrender the army I
know Custer defenders have tried to say
that it happened I'm sorry
the contemporary record is pretty clear
as one Confederate officer said I've
never seen a man leave our line I never
seen the man cut his tail between his
legs more than General Custer did but
nevertheless it is Custer who is there
his cavalry division will cut it off we
like to compare we like to argue this
part of the art an obsession of
fascination and curable disease with the
Civil War that most of us I'm sure share
I will just tell you that I think that
by war's end there is no finer combat
unit in the entire armies of Potomac
than the 3rd Calvary division from top
to bottom the troopers are veteran
they're well armed a well led a
regimental Brigade levels William wells
Pennington a brigade command sure that
what about the infantry well you know
that the infantry is going that great
infantry of Gettysburg will no longer
exist after Cold Harbor and if you did
what course will be taken care of than
that so if you're going to look at the
best combat command in the Army of
Potomac I would argue it was a third
Calvary division George Custer was not
in the room when Lee surrendered the
grip he was not there but he what he was
that he was outside rounding up old
southern friends I think seven spent the
night with them at night in his tent
they all liked them on the peninsula he
went to a wedding of a Confederate
officer and friended had been captured
he fell in love with his nursing before
in return North Custer got permission so
there you have the groom and Confederate
gray and the best man in Union blue and
they were married you know he stood for
him but the table of course that was you
Sheridan will give as a gift to Libby
Custer because he said no I'm more
responsible for this surrender and your
husband six weeks later they will be in
Washington for the grand review now
courts they claim that as Custer led the
three division down this Pennsylvania
Avenue he deliberately made his horse
rear up and please the crowd
most likely the horse was frightened by
some young woman throwing flowers at the
Mount
I'm sure Custer relished it but was
interesting in rank see read ranks
because the calvary led that day as they
would lead an army battle came the third
division who decided before the parade
that their official symbol would be a
red necktie and they wore it that day
and when it was over they will return
and say a few words to them and bid them
farewell he'd already orders to go to
Louisiana as one officer said and I
quote he is the best abri general in the
army her trooper offered this in
explanation he never asked his men to go
where he would not lead them so at the
age of 25 as George and Libby Custer
would leave the third division he would
go knowingly leave the proudest
Association of his life because this
night if you will there would be a cause
no more and I think a night needs a
cause what is happening ill-prepared
immature a war hero a household name
only lower probably than Grant Sheridan
and Sherman in the United States George
Custer will travel for the sunset
because it is in the West that George
Custer will go and it is there
unfortunately I think that most
Americans have their opinion of him
views of him and the images but what I
will tell you how he died at Appomattox
had he chosen to leave the army I think
today duster would be withstanding me
sub stored possibly not same level but
John Buford and some others probably at
ease probably joking but he deserves to
be in the back of horse soldiers
certainly during the Civil War
thank you